[Music]
I'm Kelly reading for reviewer James
swin banks after a four-year stint in
steams early access rec fest has hit the
track with surprising confidence every
event is brimming with satisfaction
showing off its impressive soft body
collision system that lets colliding
cars twist and crush with brutal realism
breakfast succeeds where it matters
becoming one of the most surprising and
gratifying racing games of the year
[Applause]
breakfast career mode is made up of five
different Championships each consisting
of various events for multi race
championships two one-off demolition
derbies that each gradually unlock as
you gain XP and increase your driver
level in addition to XP your rewards are
doled out regularly in the form of
performance parts along with credits to
buy new cars and parts with so even a
poor finish which will happen never
feels like wasted time most career
events are a simple race to the finish
rail have a handful of laps to hunt down
the opposition and score as good a
position as possible giving you a chance
to serve up mayhem while slicing through
the field race starts are a gorgeous
chaotic mess as cars jostle and barge
for position they're also where the
game's marquee destruction engine shows
of its capabilities cars fly off the
course through wooden fences and tire
barriers sending debris scattering into
the air and across the road it can be
spectacular to watch from a distance but
equally brutal when you're the one
involved in it
other event types include demolition
derbys and elimination style heat races
that normally take place on a closed
figure 8 track or an oval there's also
the occasional lawn mower derby which
shows the off the game slightly twisted
sense of humor
each mode offers some variety and
destruction and they're all visually
spectacular in their own raid damage and
wreck Fest has two settings normal and
realistic on normal you and your
opponents can survive more than your
fair share of hard hits but with
realistic conditions things get a lot
tougher in a bit more spectacular two
longer races become tests of survival as
all it takes is one bad collision to put
a card of contention or at least change
how it handles and you need to restart
the race if it all goes south while this
kind of repetition would normally be
grading the act of racing is so good
that it takes the edge off when you do
manage to escape the chaos and settle
into a good rhythm breakfast shows off
some wonderful driving physics the
transition between different road
surfaces is sublime and regardless of
whether you're driving with a
top-of-the-line racing wheel or a
gamepad the sensation of sliding around
a corner catching the rear end and
gassing it all the way out feels superb
tires slip and slide through the dirt
but scream for grip on the tarmac and
you can almost feel them flexing as the
car rolls through the corners
[Applause]
each type of car feels different to
drive some are heavier and more sluggish
while others are lighter and can corner
better but suffer more in collisions
upgrades to vehicles can substantially
alter the handling whether it's through
better performance or a stronger chassis
that's better at taking damage although
having no way of saving upgrade sets can
result in some minor headaches when
optimizing for each event type overall
it's a meaningful upgrade system with
tangible effects on the already diverse
feel of racing AI drivers race
unapologetically no matter the scenario
or difficulty level unafraid to put you
off the road if they decide they want to
get past or smashing into you headfirst
in an effort to take you out if
competing against AI isn't your bag you
can take it online and race against
others on dedicated servers or set up
your own custom race server with your
own rules and it all works smoothly
compared to the dynamic gameplay rec
fest user experience is a bit
frustrating the UI is surprisingly bland
for such a technically impressive game
with static menus and a heavy rock
soundtrack that's obnoxious enough to
warrant immediately turning the music
off with that out of the way you can
more fully appreciate the game's
excellent sound effects
throaty engines belch and roar loudly
except for the lawnmower which sounds
like thousands of angry mosquitos and
crash sounds are impactful in
bone-crunching
equally good are the game's visuals the
cars themselves while all old banged up
muscle cars look suitably mean and ready
for thrashing debris stays on the track
over the course of a race as do the
littered remains of cars that don't make
the distance it's rare when a racing
game manages to modernize and
reinvigorate an old formula with
spectacular confidence but rec fest does
just that minor issues with menus and
its soundtrack aside it wails at the
gorgeous look and wonderful driving feel
along with a damage system that
satisfies in the most brutal of fashions
with its array of different cars tracks
and event types wreck Fest is a
brilliantly fun and frenetic racing game
that can be thoroughly enjoyed by anyone
not just racing game fans
[Music]
[Music]
you